OK, let's go to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty.
Many, many people waiting anxiously to say
their piece will start today with our caller
from the three to three areacode who's calling
today from three to three.
Hello.
Yes, that's you.
Oh, my God.
I got David Pakman.
I love your show and I recommend it to Mike
doesn't even to now.
I have two questions for you.
Go first.
First of all, what do you think they can do
about the Georgia delays and in the elections?
So corrupt there that I just I would hope
that, you know, Black Lives Matter would also
like gather around the Georgia City Hall and
protest back that they're just disenfranchizing
people.
Yep.
We talked about this earlier in the week.
And if you want a preview of the voter disenfranchisement
and election fraud tactics that we are going
to see in November, just look at what happened
in Georgia earlier this week.
And, you know, certainly it has not been a
focus of the protests of the last 10 days
that that's that's OK.
The protests were about something else.
But we need every nonprofit that works on
voter disenfranchisement activated.
We need to overwhelm the vote by so much that
even by cheating, they can't win.
But if if anybody doubted and at this point,
I don't know why you would if anybody doubted
what we were going to see in November.
We saw it in Georgia this week.
And there is no one solution.
It's we've got to push for a vote by mail.
We've got to push for not closing polling
places, prevent the voter roll purges.
Anybody who can vote early, should anybody
who can vote by mail should.
But we've got to overwhelm the vote because
they're going to try to take it with these
tactics.
We they do it every year.
And Trump is extra desperate right now.
Yeah.
It was just really sad.
And all those people, especially I heard it
mostly happened in the minority communities.
Oh, well, that's a strategy that's not by
chance.
The idea is make it harder to vote in places
where at the at the at in the average, people
are more likely to vote for Democrats.
And you had people who vote in overwhelmingly
white precincts in Georgia saying, I don't
know what people are talking about.
I showed up.
I voted in five minutes.
There was nobody there, plenty of voting booths
and everything's fine.
That's the strategy.
Yeah, yeah, I heard that, I heard there was
a woman at the pole who said that she drove,
she had to wait for three hours.
She drove to a white place and saw people
just walking in.
That wasn't even a line.
Yep.
It's it's predictable and it's horrible.
Yeah, and then my final final comment is with
the Joe Rogan interview.
I love Joe Rogan, but it seems like to be
using you like a I don't know, like you're
his psychologist or stuff because he talk
so much more than normal.
It's just like I was like, would you let David
say something?
I didn't know.
I didn't notice that, to be perfectly frank.
Yes, he was going on and on and I was like,
Joe, because they like, you know, he let you
know, they let death talk a lot more.
But he was.
It was like he was waiting for you.
Like, you know, I did a unload the David Pakman
so I could just.
David's very polite.
So I'm just going to talk and talk.
I thought, I don't know if that was real.
You know, when when when it's done via Skype.
Like, I wasn't in the room with Joe.
It's sometimes maybe tougher to read when
it would be a natural time for the other person
to talk.
So maybe that was a factor.
But in the moment, I didn't notice it.
Yeah, that's probably true because I was.
The thing I thought about it like the first
time you went, it didn't seem that way.
Right?
Or maybe maybe maybe because he's he's he
doesn't see you there.
He feels the sort of maybe a little bit of
anxiety in order to try to fill the moment.
Maybe so.
You know, but you just keep talking.
Because he doesn't see a physical cue.
Right.
You're ready to jump in.
He's even going and going and going.
Well, anyway, that's it.
Thank you so much.
You know, I'm a huge fan.
I'm a member, you know.
And I recommended my cousin to be your member.
And anybody who I talked to about in terms
of like, you know, getting a good news source,
I told them, you know, data pattern is one
of the best.
Thank you.
Ill secular talk with Kaplinsky.
Yeah.
So you guys are are a number one.
Fantastic.
All right.
Appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Take care.
Great to hear from you.